I'm Terry Gerard and I'm Scoutmaster with Troop44 in Consville, Oklahoma.
This edition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now for you, Scoutmaster,
I have here in front of me another report of a discovery made by the dedicated research
Scouters at the Large Baden Collider out in Heisenberg, Arizona,
Arizona. huh,
I thought I thought Heisenberg was in Germany, but I'm uncertain about that.
Well, look anyway, the Large Baden Collider accelerates camping gear
to its terminal velocity and things collide, apparently,
And they discover interesting properties of different bits of camping gear.
and the discovery that this report announces has to do with water filters,
And it's called the water filter temporal distortion.
What they've discovered is that the stated operational time required
to filter a quart of water, expressed in minutes, will actually take
an equal number of hours.
So I guess if you've ever filtered water with a water filter,
you know what I'm talking about.
Hey, this is podcast number 284..
Well, welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Green, back to our regular good old format.
We had a vacation day last week
And but here we are, we're back again.
Fred Glover is an OH chapter advisor.
He wrote in to say thanks for your continued support of the scouting movement.
I've only been listening to the podcast for a couple of years,
but it always seemed that you were on a subject or issue
I was encountering at the time.
Thanks, Fred,
I really appreciate that.
And thanks for being a backer to. Fred did mention that in his message to me.
Also, this message from Joe Prespari,
who is the Cubmaster of Pac-23 in Burlington, Connecticut.
Hi, Clark,
Well, you've inspired me to stay in Cub scouting next year
and allow my son to move up into Boy Scouts.
I really see a need in my town for seasoned leaders to remain in Cub Scouts
and welcome the next generation of boys into the program.
It's my hope I can sway some more experienced tenured leaders to do the same.
Otherwise we're going to lose all that experience at the Cub level.
Thanks for the good work.
Well, Joe, thank you.
I'm glad that I had some small part in you're deciding to stay on with
Cubs and to stay active there.
This is something we've talked about in the past, right
That that a lot of times we just expect to lose our most experienced
Cub leaders when their own sons move up into a Boy Scout troop.
But Joe's taken a little bit of a different tack.
I think that's both noble and really, really necessary.
So once again, thanks for being in touch, Joe.
Hey, last week we were on with live chats and these happen usually
on Tuesday and Wednesday mornings, Eastern time, starting about eight o'clock.
We go to about 11 o'clock. keep an eye on my Facebook feed and my Twitter feed
and come and join us at scoutmastercgcom for a live chat.
And I wanted to say thank you to Scott Jones,
who's a scout master for Troop 911 in San Antonio, Texas, and Jeremy Snyder,
who's an assistant scout master with Troop 175 in North Ridgeville, Ohio.
Scott and Jeremy both signed on for the first time
and joined the rest of the frequent flyers that show up when we have a live chat.
Thanks for spending a little time with me.
I appreciate it.
Let me take time to ask you a favor, because I- because I do need your help.
I started blogging and podcasting back in 2005 and I really didn't plan
on what happened in the next 10 years.
It just kind of grew and I hear from a lot of folks every week
and it's really heartening to know I'm able to lend them a hand in their work as scouts.
So what I'm asking for is if you're finding the podcast and the blog posts
and all the other things that we create at scoutmastercgcom useful to you.
you can return the favor by becoming a backer, and it's pretty easy to do.
Go to scoutmastercgcom, click the support link at the top of the page
and you'll find a number of options on making a one-time kind of voluntary
subscription payment to keep things up and running.
And I want to take a moment to personally thank Owen Wilson
and Jamie Barnes, who became backers since the last podcast.
Once again, go to scoutmastercgcom,
Go to the support link at the top of the page, become a backer this week
and I'll be sure to thank you on our next podcast.
Now. last week I posted my thoughts about offering alternative wording
to the Scout Oath that would be more in line with the BSA's approval
of non-theist religious groups for participation in the Religious Emblems Program.
I'm not going to try and explain everything that was in that post
here. on the podcast,
If you go to scoutmastercgcom, look for the post that's titled
A Scout's Duty to God, and I'll link to it in the post that contains this podcast too.
Now, whenever I mention debatable issues like this,
I expect a strong response from both sides of the debate,
And I'm not real comfortable talking about debatable issues most of the time,
because it can be divisive, right?
Discussing things like this with people is always a little tricky, isn't it?
And discussing it online is even more complicated,
But I wanted to say how much I appreciate everyone who took the time
to join in the conversation and how much I appreciate the tone
of almost everybody who joined in.
You know, some people get a little strident about things
in an inappropriate manner online, and that's going to happen,
But when we're talking about scouts, for the most part, people you know
are very respectful of each other's opinions.
What that really gets me thinking about, though, is whenever
we end up talking about these issues- right-
And these are usually issues affecting membership
and how we interpret and present the principles that scouting is based on-
You have to examine what you're doing as an organization.
I've spent the whole of my adult life being a scouter
and being associated with the Boy Scouts of America,
And you know the good old BSA has been through some difficult times
in its century of existence, but perhaps none are more difficult
than the times that we're in now,
And when I think about organizations and changes and things like that,
I think I think a useful allegory is that organizations
are kind of like ships on the ocean.
Now, if you're going to build a ship that carries a lot of people,
you want to build something that's stable and safe,
that reacts predictably to the winds and waves and currents and things,
And so when you build an organization as big as the BSA,
it's got to be stable.
But to get that stability sometimes you have to be kind of impenetrable
and inflexible like a ship, right?
I mean, if you're building a big ship,
you don't want to build the whole out of cellophane,
You want to build it out of something pretty impenetrable
and inflexible like steel, right?
And we build organizations that way.
We build them to be very stable,
And that makes things kind of difficult. when it comes to evolution and change.
The best ship is still going to have a lot of drag associated with it,
And when it's a really big ship, it's going to take a lot of time to turn.
And so, if you follow my allegory, the ocean that we're floating on
is the culture, and culture is pretty wide and deep
And it's more fluid and changeable than the organizational ships
that we're traveling in.
Big organizations like the BSA embrace cultural change pretty slowly,
But to add to the complexity of the whole thing,
our individual members and our young people they embrace change pretty quickly.
Yeah, you ever noticed something about scouts?
Scouts have this kind of unsettling ability
to take the values and ethics that scouting has developed in them
and to apply them without much regard to what the broader organization has to say.
Scouts take things literally. and a really good example of that:
Go work on a camp staff with a lot of young people sometime
and you'll you'll understand exactly what what I mean.
They understand the values and the ethics of scouting
And sometimes they get crosswise to organizational imperatives.
They come to a different conclusion about exactly how these things
ought to be carried out.
And I'll tell you something: anything like the BSA
is going to find itself on the wrong side of history from time to time.
Big national organizations are reluctant to face cultural changes,
especially when championing a set of values and ethics
that we say are unchanging and unalterable.
But if you look at the history of the scouting movement
and scouting organizations, there's been a lot of changes
about how they interpret and express the values that we hold.
We find new meanings, our world grows bigger,
we become more diverse, and that diversity makes us stronger.
You can look at diversity as being something that dilutes you,
But I don't agree. OK. I think diversity makes us very strong.
Now I'm 55 years old and if you're a part of my generation or older,
I've got something to share with you,
And if you're younger, you can keep listening,
That's OK. But think about this:
Our grandparents notice things that they didn't like in our parents' generation,
And our parents noticed the same types of things
they didn't like about our generation,
And now it's basically our turn to be parents and grandparents
and notice in our children's and our grandchildren's generation
Things that we don't particularly approve of
or things that seem to have changed, things that look scary to us.
What you and I are noticing is basically the same thing
that our parents and our grandparents were noticing.
It's not so much things changing around us
as our own perspective changing as we are getting a little older.
Yeah, things changed around us.
I understand that, but I think we older people
fall into this comfortable trap of looking at anything that's changing
and moaning and groaning about how things are different now,
because we're a little bit afraid of what comes next. for us,
It's harder to accept changes and to look at things
from new perspectives the older you get-
And also men. we need to defer to the youthful energy
and initiative of young people, of our scouts and younger scouts.
We need to listen because there's a lot of wisdom
in what they're having to say and they can help us navigate
what's changing around us, because I'm afraid otherwise
we'll have an organization with a few scouts
and a lot of old geezers like me. right,
And I got to say it's the old geezers
that kind of run the show. as far as the PSA is concerned,
If you go to a meeting, take a look around,
You see the age, gender and race
of the people who are making decisions is pretty much, you know,
pretty much the same.
And when we old geezers sit around
we're not too sure what's going wrong.
We think we just have to market ourselves better
or repackage our message or add more programs
that 50 plus year old men think boys would be interested in.
But what scouts do is not the problem.
That program is still relevant, exciting and engaging.
We don't have to adorn it with bobbles
or repackage it in shiny paper.
We've tried that many, many times before and it never works.
Those aren't the kind of changes we need.
I'm saying that most of the people
who are making the decisions in the PSA
are kind of old geezers like me,
And I don't think they're bad people, far from it.
I know that they're people of goodwill
as concerned with and engaged in scouting as anybody.
I do think, though, that they're reluctant
to make any big changes, and I can't blame them,
because change is scary and uncertain
And it can be tremendously difficult,
It can be kind of exhausting and it can be divisive,
And change can be seen as an admission
that you were doing things wrong, and that's humbling,
And so it becomes a very complex question, doesn't it?
But I have to say I've watched the rest
of the world scouting movement confront
the changes the society makes over the past few decades
and do the hard work required to serve
as many youth as possible
with the really wonderful program
and the vast potential that scouting promises.
And I don't think anybody from any of the different
organizations in the world of scouting
would tell you that change was easy, because it isn't.
But even so, these organizations have stabilized
and even grown over the past 15 years,
as our beloved, arthritic old PSA
has shrunk by one third of its youth members,
That's a million young people,
If you sit and talk about it and you think about it. of course
there's a number of different reasons that membership is down,
But I think what we have to ask ourselves seriously
is what our organization will look like five years from now
If we were to not make any changes at all,
not to ask ourselves questions and innovate our programs
and our approaches, because I think that future looks pretty grim.
But if we listen to our young people,
we'll find a lot of energy and inspiration in what they have to say
And if we understand our aim is to give as many young people
as possible the advantage of having the wonderful opportunities
that scouting offers, we're going to make some changes
and we're going to start to see things look up.
So there we go.
I'll get down off my soapbox now and we'll move on,
And in the remainder of this podcast
I've got some email questions to answer.
So let's get started. shall we
Send it by name
Email? that is, folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
Brittany Henson is from PAC 691 in Longwood, Florida,
And she wrote to say: I'm a scout mom.
I've recently taken over the leadership of my son,
My son's- Weeblows 1 den
And I've been told I need to run the den like a Boy Scout patrol.
I like the idea, but I'm a little confused.
Do you have any pointers on how I can do this
And what are the main points of a Boy Scout patrol?
How strict is the group size?
I only have four Weeblows right now.
I do have all the information on Weeblows requirements
and the new program.
I guess what I don't entirely understand
is the purpose of a patrol
Other than the boys and I meeting once a week.
are there other considerations?
Well, Brittany, that's an excellent question,
And as for what scout patrols do
and how you incorporate it into Weeblows,
it's not all that difficult or mysterious
to tell you the truth.
So don't let the idea of a patrol confuse you,
because it's actually pretty much the way things
work, naturally with scouts and with boys. to begin with,
A patrol is just really a small group of scouts
who work together under their own leadership.
Now in Weeblows, the boys are of an age
where they can begin to take on
more and more responsibility for themselves,
And we want to encourage that.
As a den leader, you'll want to explain
that they're getting a little older.
It's time for them to start learning
how to work together as a patrol
and how to lead each other
through the things that they do.
So they can do things like choose a patrol name
and elect a patrol leader,
and the patrol leader can start helping you lead the den.
I think it'd be a good idea to give all the Weeblows
the chance to be patrol leader,
So you may want to have a talk with them
about exactly how you're going to make that happen,
And talking to them is something
that I really encourage you to do.
Look at your work as a den leader
as helping the Weeblows organize themselves
and make things happen,
rather than thinking you have to be the expert
and know all the answers.
I'm a big advocate of talking to our scouts
about how they'd like to make things happen.
You don't have to know at all
or be an expert.
You can learn right along with them.
If you take the materials that explain the program,
if you take the Weeblows handbook
and you start discussing with them
how to make things happen
and you use those resources
to define the way you're going to do it,
you'll be surprised at how much they can actually do
and how excited they are
when they're actually having something to do
with leading themselves.
I heard from William Castler in Wasilla, Alaska,
and he said. 22 years ago
my boys came home
and they asked me if they could join scouting.
I said okay
and I found myself as the PAC committee chairman.
So I've been a den leader, assistant scout,
master, unit commissioner,
merit badge counselor and more besides,
And when I first got started
I found it difficult to find good information,
especially when working with parents and other adults.
Several years ago
I started to put out a weekly newsletter
and I've included your excellent posts
and your material in my newsletter as often as I could,
but I'm in the process of changing the format
to a webpage
and I'm writing to ask if you'd had any objections
if I took your posts
and used them on this new site.
Before I answer, William,
I also heard from Pierre,
who said I'm working on a little camp book
for my scouts
with useful tips and things for them to use.
I'd like to use some of the material
that you've produced
and translated into French,
and I can send the finished book
and all the translated documents
that you add to your website.
I wanted to find out if that's okay with you,
and that's from Pierre Courdiere,
who is with the FSS,
the Fraternal Salut Scouts in France.
So William and Pierre
and everybody else is listening.
Anything that I've made,
anything I've written or produced,
the infographics and all that stuff
is freely offered to support scouting,
no matter where you are.
The only thing that I ask
is that if you use anything
that I've created in your materials,
all you do is let people know where you found it,
Give them a link back to the website
or to say that you found it at scoutmastercgcom.
So if you're working on a project
and you want to incorporate some of the material
or some of the writing that I've done,
please take this as a blanket approval to do so,
so long as you, like I said,
give proper attribution to where you found it
and who created it.
Heard from Joel Irway.
He said this:
I'm an assistant scout master with Troop 637
in Onsted, Michigan.
As an assistant scout master,
I'm not part of the committee,
nor do I sit on boards of review
and, in an effort to keep the Troop youth led,
I'm really not supposed to have an influence
on patrol leaders council meetings.
So with all the stuff I am not supposed to do,
I'm a little lost as to what I should be doing.
I asked another assistant scout master from our Troop
and he didn't have an answer for me either.
We both felt like this was a good question for you
and that it's pretty likely
we're not the only assistant scout masters
who are a little puzzled.
Well, Joel, that is an excellent question.
You're puzzled because, unfortunately,
the way the vast majority of Troops
handle the assistant scout master position,
I don't know,
it just doesn't make a lot of sense to me. sometimes
There are frankly-
oh I'm gonna get myself in trouble by saying this,
but listen, frankly,
there are just too many adult volunteers
who have little or no idea
of what scouting is or their role in making it happen.
Somewhere along the way,
I think we got the idea
that the more volunteers we have, the better,
but this is not necessarily the case. okay,
If you have a troop with 30 scouts
and 12 assistant scout masters,
what you really end up with is either
the assistant scout masters kind of doing the things
that the scouts are supposed to do,
or you have a parents club within the troop,
and that can cause problems too,
And it's great fun
for all the people who are volunteering,
but maybe not so much for the scouts who are involved.
Now, to tell you the truth,
there really shouldn't be very much
for assistant scout masters-
or the scout master for that matter- to do.
I mean, when there's an engaged youth leadership
running their program.
you know, if you think about it,
there's not a whole lot of use
for more than two or three scouters on an outing.
There's almost nothing for them to do at meetings
that involve the program and the meeting directly.
but I frequently see troops with 10 or more,
and sometimes many more, assistant scout masters.
I have to wonder what they actually do.
Now, my ideal setup is a scout master
with two assistant scout masters
for any reasonably sized troop.
One of the assistant scout masters
is nominally the first assistant
And he's the guy who's on deck to take over
when the scout masters ready to hand things over.
And ideally there'd be a date certain for that transition.
We'd know, you know, that the current scout master
is gonna serve for the next two or three years
and we know the date
where there's gonna be a transition.
So our first assistant is getting prepared
And there's a second assistant scout master
who becomes the first assistant scout master
when there's that transition.
So at each transition of who's the scout master
and assistant scout master, post comes open
and the committee appoints someone
who's fully committed to developing the skills required,
And I think personally
there should be some very high expectations
of the adults who are chosen to be scout master
and assistant scout master.
Now, any responsible committee should be sure
of who the next scout master will be,
And ideally they'll have a couple of people
ready to take the job on.
Now, some years back
we trimmed our assistant scout master list
down to three or four
And we asked all the other adults
registered as assistant scout masters
to change their registration
to be members of the committee,
And at that time
we had a lot of assistant scout masters,
probably close to 10..
They were mostly doing committee work anyway
And the committee was kind of thin.
So changing the positions made a lot of sense
And as a result
we've had a pretty substantial advancement team
of four or five people.
So setting up boards of review
and tracking advancement and things like that
is pretty light lifting for a group that size.
We have a gear guy- and presently that's me-
who keeps an eye on all the gear
and works with the quarter master
and a number of other folks doing committee work
of one kind or another.
Now that's what works for me
And that may help you
and your troops sort out what happens next
If you have a scout master
who doesn't know when they're going to be stepping down.
I think it's an important discussion
to have with the committee.
I suggest most scout masters would serve
for maybe a maximum of five years.
I went on for 30.
And that's kind of an anomaly
And I know there's a lot of long-tenured
scout masters out there.
But realistically
I think five years,
three to five years,
is a pretty realistic commitment for most people.
Then you have a date out there.
It's not that we appoint a scout master
and they serve on in perpetuity with no end in sight,
because usually there's an end in sight
And putting a date on that is gonna be helpful,
because then the troop can appoint
a first and second assistant scout master
And then the assistant scout masters
will have some real direction in what they're doing.
So I think that any troops should decide
how many assistant scout masters they actually need,
what expectations they should meet,
and only appoint that many.
Anyone else interested in volunteering,
they can serve on the committee
And if they're really interested
in being an assistant scout master
and all the spots are filled
serving on the committee,
they'll be there when one of those spots comes open.
Now Joel got back to me and said:
well, in our troop
only two of us are assistant scout masters
and everyone else is on the committee.
I think the troop is about halfway
to being completely functional as a patrol method troop.
We have some strong youth leaders
and the patrols are there,
but they're mostly just on paper at this point.
What did your assistant scout masters do
to help you over the years?
Well, another great question,
because my assistant scout masters were there
in the role of a pretty basic function of an assistant
to take over things when I wasn't able to be there.
They were also more sets of eyes and ears
observing what was going on
and we could discuss then what was happening with scouts.
As for working with the youth leadership,
there's always a lot of strength
and a number of opinions and voices,
but that all should be coordinated
and it's best for the ideas and comments
to come through the scout master,
because it's just less confusing for the scouts
and a lot more effective that way.
And the way that that would happen
is myself and my assistants-
we would talk all the time.
We would talk a lot
and we would share our observations with each other
And if we came up with ideas or suggestions
for the patrol leaders, counselor or the youth leaders,
then it was my job to take that to them.
Now I found it useful to have some assistants
mentor specific youth leaders over time
when there was a specific goal in mind.
I didn't set up permanent relationships like that,
because just working with a youth leader for a time-
it might be a couple of weeks or a couple of months-
to help them with one thing or another
was often very useful.
My assistant scout masters were also a great sounding board
for my ideas and for the scout's ideas
and to help me find solutions to problems
or to work with me to counsel scouts
in the midst of some dilemma,
And there's a nominal chain of command involved here.
but it's all more about coordination than control.
Now you note that your troop has some work to do
towards fully getting the most out of the patrol system,
And I gotta tell you, Joel,
that's pretty much what everybody tells me
And the way I always felt as scout master-
we had never really arrived.
We were always just traveling in that direction.
But the real answer to your questions here
is gonna come from the scout master.
If you and your fellow assistants
are uncertain of how to be supportive.
I've asked the scout master to sit down with you
to talk through what's happening
and what his goals are
and how you can coordinate efforts
And, as I said before,
I would plan on who the next scout master is gonna be
and when that will happen.
And the ongoing work that you're doing is pretty simple:
to support and develop our youth leadership
and to be part of that adult leadership team
with the scout master,
but to understand the importance of coordinating input
for the scouts through the scout master.
Well, thanks for listening to this 284th edition
of the scout master podcast.
Here's how to keep in touch:
Go to scoutmastercgcom
and you'll see that we have a blog there
and you can subscribe to receive updates
to the blog by email.
You can experience the wonders of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama of social media.
That's right. join the nearly 10,000 folks
who like the scout master blog on Facebook.
Tweet along with the course
of 1300 other tweeters on Twitter.
Pin the pultritudinous Pinterest pictures
proffered publicly, with 2,300 other
prolific Pinterest pinners.
How about that?
Watch us at scoutmastercg on YouTube.
and? but look, I understand with this social media stuff
Some of you can't face. Facebook
or Twitter makes you better
and you have no interest in Pinterest
and you don't put the? U in YouTube,
but that's all right.
Zoom into the late 90s and send me an email.
You can get in touch with me, Clark Green,
with your comments and questions
at Clark at scoutmastercgcom.
It's C-L-A-R-K-E at scoutmastercgcom,
And if all else fails, you can write your message
on a piece of paper, seal it in a bottle
and bury it in any campfire circle.
I'll be sure to get it,
because I have agents everywhere.
It only remains for me to remind you
that the scout master blog
and the scout master podcast
are not official publications
of any scouting organization,
nor they endorsed or sponsored
by any scouting organization
such as the Boy Scouts of America.
No, it's just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun,
here he is our founder, Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping,
Why? thank you, sir.
Until next time, everyone.